I drink hi Stuart
so this is very exciting for me to be
having a conversation on stage with you
because I spent the last year having a
conversation with you in my mind while I
was writing my book the last chapter of
my book it's called saving the real
world together and it's looking at big
future forecasting games and getting
gamers to think long term we even have a
design for a thousand year game that you
know with the goal of having at least
50% of the planet playing the same game
by the end of the first 100 years and so
I was thinking a lot about your work
your ideas about seizing the millennium
but also your illustrious career as a
game designer which is you know I
brought my copy of the new games book I
don't know how many people here are
aware Stuart's illustrious career as a
game designer some of my favorite games
growing up are in this book and actually
one of the reasons why I'm the game
designer is because you and some of your
friends out here in the Bay Area decided
to start a games movement now I don't
know if it was explicitly to change the
world I definitely had that ethos
well here the origin story yes please
two feet story as I was hanging out with
Gregory Bateson in those days this is
late 70s getting on into you know
actually early seventies and he had been
there when theory of games was developed
by Jonathan Newman and we were talking
about that and the Cold War which was
still in full tilt at that point he said
three games is really brilliant but it
has this terrible black which it does
not have it within the theory any theory
of how to change the rules I thought I
thought you know when I was a kid we
were changing the rules games all the
time so we played baseball out in the
side lot next to the house I grew up and
then there really wasn't room for three
bases so we figured out how to play
baseball the two bases and it would
change the game according to how many
kids there actually
there to play and so on and I thought
all kids know about changing the rules
of games except the ones that get stuck
in the Little League World or something
like that and but then grown-ups getting
into this mode of teaching Little League
and following big league and going by
these are the rules and that's the way
it is folks and I looked at games like
professional football I thought that was
actually for teams on the field there's
the team a and Team B were almost
exactly like each other not very
interesting with raging there then
there's a referees that's a really
different group of people and then
there's the audience and with television
audience overlooking this whole thing so
that's these four entities actually
determine how professional football
moves forward
that started me in the mode of well if
we're ever going to get out of the cold
water we're going to have to change the
rules by which we're playing it because
it's a game which must not be won by
anybody and so the intent of the new
games tournament initially did it with a
thing called World War four I was hired
by the war resisters League to do a
public event for them and I said let's
have a war by then it was too late for
them to say you know so we went ahead in
the war and I did some games for them
earth ball and a game called slaughter
which they loved because what I knew it
would be the cases these were usually
mostly young men who were facing the
draft that's who the war resisters
League was yet no more and what they
needed to do was bodily fight and not
get killed and not be involved in a big
stupid mission and so on and they'd
really loved it so I'd invented games
they could do that and they were violent
they are right on the edge of getting
hurt but one of our rules was play hard
play fair nobody hurt and that was part
of the design problem so the idea of the
new games tournament was new games okay
we're gonna have a great big tug of war
let's get a hose or 300 feet long that's
about that big around and first deal was
a Lomond start so people on two sides of
this Creek had to stand back ten feet
away from the rope
I fired a starter gun Wow and everybody
had run to the rope pick it up and start
pulling that was kind of fun went on for
a while and one of the things I noticed
is the on lookers would see the the team
they were closest to starting to lose
and then that would go join the rope and
so it balanced back and forth and went
on for quite a while they wanted to keep
the game going they were effective yeah
we'll come back this is I think the
important point because then the next
thing we do okay that was violent and
interesting because people ran into each
other and so let's make a really violent
and interesting and the deal is that you
have to go across the this Canyon
between the two teams and grab the rope
on the other side bang and so the two
teams are running through each other and
the bottom is freek been tripping each
other up and clambering up the other
side and then not knowing whether to run
out and grab the rope at a distance
they're all crowded up of it you know
everybody's figuring out the strategy as
it emerges around them is that complete
melee people loved it Wow can we do that
again so what I was discovering is that
the fun of play was for people to get in
this mode like kids of how can we make
this game more interesting that was the
breakthrough that made new games work in
the somewhat more candy-ass Games wound
up in the book the violent ones that I
thought were way more fun for people
which were much more grab-ass again it
was you know young males and females and
lured from hanging out with American
Indians that games that involve a
certain amount of contact not actually
of a violent but contact is most fun for
young people and that also as part of
this action so that's the story the new
games tournament so I was thinking we
could take this opportunity so the
founders of the new games
the lifelong students of the new games
still making games trying to change the
world I am that we could take one of
these awesome games and think about
reinventing it for the future so I was
thinking the the earth ball game right
so how many you guys have played with an
earth ball right a lot of people's that
surprising number actually it looks like
250 times the size of a volleyball is
that about the right I believe that was
a reference yeah and earth ball is a six
foot high push ball as they were called
a cage ball and I big breakthrough was
to get a friend Roy Siebert has a canvas
to paint it like the earth yes and then
we had into the field or the other yeah
okay so here's what I'm thinking so I
know that in the historic accounts of
earth ball that's apparently sometimes
people would want to keep the game going
so much rather than have one side win
they would switch sides in the game it's
it true that a game went longer than a
day is that true it should be yeah it
should be it could've been that's the
legend that's the Midianite yeah I wish
I could believe because I know the kind
of games that we make were totally based
on that idea of the infinite game of
finite games you play to win infinite
games you play to get as many people
into the game as possible and we don't
leave the game and to make right the
rules must change in order to make it
better so do any of the online games
have that quality at this point you can
changed the rules none of none of the
major games have have where you can
change the rules what they do have is
where you can design your own level
where you can and then share it with
other players and get feedback on
whether that it that level is fair
whether it's engaging whether it's fun
so there is definitely a sense of
learning what's happening I think with
gamers that most gamers are getting now
their hands dirty with design and so
it's sort of helping them think about
about how to make a good game and I'm
thinking there are a lot of people like
designing iphone games app games because
it's sort of cheap and easy to do yeah
yeah well it's certainly lowered the
threshold for for designing for
designing games and getting something
out there although actually there's a
whole new movement of people to design
like 8-bit games because there are these
computers being sold in developing
markets that are like educational game
consoles and they come with a cartridge
with 250 games I mean she's just like
you're literally just like your old
Atari cartridge and there's a great
opportunity to instead of reselling
developing game communities old Atari
games we could sell them new games like
what are the games the mythologies and
stuff we want to have them grab it and
that's a really low threshold for even I
who I'm not a good programmer a coder
even I could that's great you could make
that but so I'm thinking cuz I want to
do global I'm like Tiffany I want to
have everybody in the whole world
collaborating so I was thinking what if
we tried to design an earth ball game
that was a 10 year game now I need your
help designing this so some of the
things that I'm thinking about because
the goal this game would be well there'd
be a couple things you'd really have to
think at a planetary scale I think so
you'd want to put the boundaries the
where the goal is maybe like at the
poles or maybe the west coast and the
East Coast if it was just a u.s. game
but that doesn't seem fun enough to me
but so we'd have to think about I need
your help designing where the the goal
should be and then to figure out you
know where can you go over the next
decade and if you know maybe we put a
goal in North Korea for example and what
would that mean to have by the end of 10
years moving towards you know millions
of gamers getting the ball in the goal
just for example to think you know
that's in the realm of the crazy you
know is there a game that we could
design that would marshal eyes people
you know around some some really epic
epic goal across the planet and and and
to keep the ball safe
for ten years yeah this is a I would
treat it as a your own metaphor kind of
deal where the the the earth and the
earth ball are some sense merge so one
of the things I learned from watching
people mess around with volleyball which
people do mess around it's a very
forgiving sport you do various numbers
of people on each team and so on and as
soon as they get into the mode of let's
screw around with the rules one of them
one of the rules that turns out to be
very popular with people is how about
the deal is all the rules of volleyball
apply but the goal is to go as long as
you can before the ball touches the
ground and so instead of trying to spike
it if than that to you know get it to
the ground before the other team can get
to it
you're lobbying it over the net so the
other team can get to it and they do
their three hits and they lob it back
over and turns out to be very difficult
but what's neat about it is it's like
the last two minutes in football it gets
very tense and you're screaming for
somebody you know to commit their body
to make the huge dive to make the save
can keep the game going for everybody
and in it you know it's it is a
sweetiepie game is very collaborative
and all of that on the other hand of the
side that finally drops the ball feels
terrible so that's one thing that and
you mentioned it when the earth ball
goes from one end of the field or the
other people wind up trying to keep it
going and people actually defect to this
team that's almost about to lose so one
potentially interesting thing okay
another version of Earth ball it is
amazing to me the people totally
invented is you've got this six foot
high ball it's pretty heavy and up
people described if they get on their
back and put their feet underneath a
ticket Street and then the deal gets to
be how high can you kick it but then
another bunch of people gather around
them to be sure that no matter how high
they kick it it doesn't go out and fall
on the ground and spontaneously there
becomes this flame of a kind of a
fountain or earth ball going up and
four hours in the deal is to keep the
ball up and the people on they get
exhausted pretty quick but by then the
people who have come over to see the
weird thing going on I've gotten sucked
in a game when somebody is totally
losing it on the ground somebody else
fills in so an interesting earth ball
game would be to have maybe two earth
balls maybe more start with two and they
started in Antipodes interposes sides of
the earth and the deal is that they will
progress around the earth in opposite
directions maybe they're like this and
ideally pass each other and whoever gets
to the same point you haven't gone all
the way around the world and you'd have
some rules about you can't use airplanes
and stuff like that but you've got to
keep it in the air the whole time people
have got to personally hold up this
heavy earth the whole time and if the
others standing on it and there's all
the other stuff and maybe neither team
will win maybe they drop the ball or
maybe you know one actually does come
out again but it's an epic thing that
everybody gets to watch that's one go I
love that I love I mean it's it's
metaphorical without being obnoxiously
full of content and and do you have to
do this I mean it's sort of instilling
that that what we were saying this
irrational myth that we the earth is on
our shoulders sort of it's still that
yeah Atlas didn't shrugged we call it
yeah how would you do the game and then
a little wind-up here okay
how would you do that oh how would I do
that game that particular the earth game
well let me actually I was really struck
by your idea of your visualization of
the ball going up and down and I mean
the Olympics are something interesting
to reference because that idea of the
Olympic flame to keep going and like
what would it mean to come
relieve somebody in the circle right and
how big could you make the circle and
how many balls could you keep going and
it's almost like having a you know the
long now clock in the desert could you
put something like this in a desert
somewhere and this becomes its own kind
of Mecca or pilgrimage for people who
want to you know experience taking care
of the earth there's an infinite game
that they can go and join for a period
of time just like having a lifetime on
the real earth yeah I like it
all right we're in I'll see you next
week for the first design meeting yes
let's do it so wrapping up I've got one
question is there anybody in this
audience it's actually been here through
this whole event I'm awed this bear in
mind this is one tiny fragment of the
long conversation which we call
civilization it's been very interesting
to have this highly faceted fragment of
it I should be saying thanks to the
contemporary Jewish museum for having us
here thank you indeed
[Applause]
and at this very moment our words are
being parsed by so so limited out in the
lobby and sliced six ways from Sunday
and revealed to us is holding deeper
truths thank you so so and I believe
that long-player has exactly a hundred
and sixty minutes left to play of the
current set of the thousand-year musical
event that is going on across the street
and I recommend you have a taste if you
haven't yet it is it is a step out of
the busyness of time that we've been
talking about much tonight into this
other frame of reference and that's why
we love it so much along now thank you
so long
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you